and the oscar goes to
nomad land nomad land dominated the 93rd
academy awards
the film won best picture its star
francis mcdormand best actress
and director chloe zhao best director
the first woman of color
and only the second woman ever to win
the category
so this is for anyone
who has the faith and the courage to
hold down to the goodness in themselves
and to hold on to the goodness in each
other
in the critically acclaimed film
mcdormand plays an aging widow
uprooted by economic change traveling
the back roads of the western u.s in a
battered van
it's her third oscar maybe when i die
and i like work
thank you for knowing that and thanks
for this
anthony hopkins the father in a surprise
anthony hopkins won best actor for his
role in the father
many hollywood observers thought the
late chadwick boseman
who passed away last year from cancer at
age
43 would be chosen for his dynamic
performance
in ma rainey's black bottom
it's not a question of violence or
non-violence it's a question
of resistance to fascism or
non-existence within fascism
while white performers won the top
prizes nine actors and actresses of
color were nominated for awards
the winners included daniel kaluuya for
supporting actor
in judas and the black messiah and
yo jung yoon as supporting actress in
menari
i'd like to thanks to my two boys
who made me go out and work so
be loved son all i know
this is the result because mommy worked
so hard
the best international feature award
went to another round from denmark
it looks at how alcohol impacts
relationships
due to the covet 19 pandemic the
traditional red carpet was downsized and
socially distanced
a severely limited number of nominees
and guests were allowed inside the venue
at la's union station with covet-tested
participants
rotated in and out during the show
the show's television ratings in decline
for years were predicted to be
its lowest ever
[Applause]
but there were some fun moments like
mcdormand
howling at the moon
[Applause]
and glenn close doing a rump shaking
dance in a
sparkly blue dress
the movie industry is going through
sweeping changes
as streaming video rapidly overtakes
cinematic releases of films but with all
that the oscars remain
hollywood and the film industry's most
sought after prize
and it's likely to stay that way for
years to come
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles